hallo 2023 ist wieder da oh malwanne und
willkommen in diesem neuen Video heute
machen wir einen ganz klassisches
Q&A my back to the roots und ihr habt
mir ganz viele Fragen auf Instagram
gestellt und ich hoffe dass ich welche
davon beantworten kann oh das schon das
Ende ich glaube es ist das beste so ins
Jahr rein zu starten weil ich wirklich
auch ein bisschen planlos bin ich bin
ehrlich mit euch so ein komischer insta
Waffel fragt wann kommt wieder was mit
Kelly und Freddy ich vermisse die beiden
wirklich sehr und ich vermisse Sachen
mit denen zu drehen aber Köln Berlin ne
das alte Thema ich kann halt nicht
ständig nach Köln die kommt nie nach
Berlin also wann können wir drehen hast
du dir für dieses Jahr etwas vorgenommen
wunderbare Frage da kommen wir schon zu
unserem Sponsor des Videos Spaß dieses
Jahr wird ziemlich aufregend für Timo
und mich denn wir haben uns
eine Wohnung gekauft wir haben sie aber
schon vor zwei Jahren gekauft es
ist echt und wie ihr euch schon denken
könnt diese Wohnung wird gerade noch
erst gebaut und durch manche
Gegebenheiten sei es
ein bisschen Corona Nachwirkungen es
dauert sehr lange und viel länger als
erwartet was aber nicht so schlimm ist
es ist nur ein bisschen
ärgerlich mit unserem Kredit weil jetzt
müssen wir manche Sachen Zahlen die wir
nicht gedacht hätten dass wir sie zahlen
müssen z.B so etwas wie
Bereitstellungszinsen aber wo wir schon
mal beim Thema Kredit sind kommen wir
zum Sponsor dieses Videos anifin ich
hatte bis zum Wohnungsbau jetzt wirklich
wenig mit Krediten zu tun was ich aber
weiß ist das Kredite überall drin
stecken wo man es auch manchmal gar
nicht erwartet oder denkt dass man einen
Kredit abgeschlossen hat wenn man sich
zum Beispiel online etwas kauft solltest
jetzt also gerade kleinere Kredite
Dispos oder Ratenzahlungen in Höhe von
bis zu 20.000 € am Laufen haben kann die
anifin dabei helfen aus dieser
schuldenspielerle rauszubrechen und das
ganz einfach mit der App in der anifin
bei eurem Kreditgeber ein oder ladet ein
Bild hoch auf welchem ersichtlich ist
wie hoch noch euer abzuzahlender Kredit
ist und so einfach ist es auch schon
eine Anfrage bei anifin zu stellen nur
wenn any von euch bessere Konditionen zu
einem bestehenden Kredit geben kann
bekommt ihr ein Angebot zugeschickt und
könnt sehen wie viel Ihr sparen könnt
bis hierhin ist alles kostenlos und
unverbindlich erst wenn ihr das Angebot
annehmt werdet Ihr Kunde bei anifin euer
Kredit wird dann abbezahlt und nun seid
ihr monatlich eure Rate bei any Finn in
der App kannst du auch jederzeit deine
Raten Höhe anpassen oder Sonderzahlung
leisten um deine Schulden schneller
loszuwerden ihr könnt euch jetzt hier
auch Rezension einblenden aber wenn ihr
wirklich interessiert daran seid
schneller aus euren Schulden
rauszukommen dann schaut euch doch
einfach mal die anifin App selber an die
ist natürlich in der Videobeschreibung
verlinkt und falls ihr dann euer
persönliches Angebot von anifin annehmt
habe ich übrigens noch einen Rabattcode
malwanne für 20 € Rabatt auf eure erste
Rate aber auch wenn es Angebote wie enge
finden gibt bitte seit achtsam mit Raten
Käufen und Krediten man kann da
schneller den über verlieren als man
denkt und jetzt geht es weiter was euch
wirklich extrem interessiert hat war das
ganze Thema rund ums Heiraten und auch
Kinder kriegen ich weiß das ist ein sehr
kontroverses Thema weil manche das
überhaupt nicht mögen wenn man nach
Kindern fragt ich kann auch verstehen
warum das so ist ich persönlich finde es
jetzt nicht schlimm wenn man mich nach
Kindern fragt was soll ich sagen also
ich kann mir schon vorstellen zu
heiraten definitiv ich möchte ein
schönes weißes Kleid tragen und alle
sagen an dem Tag auf mich schauen und
ich bin mit Timo ja auch schon über 5
Jahre zusammen also könnte man schon
denken dass wir es vielleicht noch
länger schaffen ich kann euch nur sagen
wenn es mal passieren sollte ihr werdet
die ersten sein die davon erfahren keine
Sorge werden wir ein neues Format sehen
was Formate auf meinem Kanal angeht bin
ich zurzeit sehr verwirrt und
unentschlossen ich liebe drei kognitz
die ballern dieses Format wird es geben
bis ich irgendwann ins Gras beiße wie
schmeckt absoluter Klassik hier auf
meinem Kanal und das wird auch immer mal
wieder geben ich weiß nicht warum ich
irgendwann die Lust dazu verloren habe
wie schmeckt zu machen oder dass das so
wenig gekommen welche Laser Art hattest
du für deine Augen hast du es bis jetzt
bereut weil sie es noch nicht
mitbekommen habt ich habe mir meine
Augenlasern lassen mit der smile Reflex
Methode ich glaube so heißt sie auf
jeden Fall hatte ich so ein Laser meinem
Auge und dann wurde die Haut in meinem
Auge so hochgeklappt dann wurde da
irgendwas rausgezogen was ich bis heute
nicht verstehe und dann wurde wieder
zugeklappt und dann war es eigentlich
schon fertig und bereuen tue ich auch
gar keinen Fall ich sehe mich in dem
Kamera Suche und sie ist einfach scharf
ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch noch daran
erinnern könnt aber immer wenn ich
Videos gedreht habe und dann in den
Sucher reingeguckt dann habe ich meine
Augen so zusammengekniffen um zu gucken
ob ich irgendwie scharf bin ob ich das
Bild gut aussieht und so sehe ich das
jetzt einfach ganz klar
werden wir irgendwann mal heiraten
okay ist das der ist das der Moment
und diese Operation kostet 4900 € und
ich würde es immer wieder machen ganz
ehrlich wie geht's dir zur Zeit mental
wie geht's dir mit deinen Panikattacken
und all dem Druck ich bin mit meinem
Panikattacken depressiven Phasen so
freundschaftlich unterwegs ich weiß dass
sie mir eigentlich nur helfen wollen und
das ist nichts schlimmes ist es gibt
aber natürlich hinter den Kulissen noch
einige Sachen mehr die so in meinem
Leben passieren wie zum Beispiel ein
Wohnungsbau das ist ja auch natürlich
sehr viel Stress aber ich stecke zurzeit
tatsächlich in einem gerichtlichen
Verfahren aber nicht wegen meiner Steuer
das würden jetzt wahrscheinlich viele
denken weil ich habe da so eine
Steuerprüfung gehabt aber da lief alles
super also fast super ich habe noch
nicht das endgültige Ergebnis ich werde
euch nicht sagen welches Thema das hat
es geht eher in die private als in die
berufliche Richtung und das beschäftigt
mich zur Zeit und das beschäftigt mich
mehr als ich zugeben möchte dass die
Geschichte läuft jetzt auch schon seit
paar Monaten weil so ein gerichtliches
Verfahren oder wenn sowas ins Rollen
gebracht wird das geht ja nicht von
heute auf morgen das ist jetzt nächste
Woche soweit dass es endlich in Richtung
Ende geht und darauf freue ich mich ich
hoffe dass alles natürlich zu meinen
Gunsten entschieden wird und das alles
schnell entschieden wird und es dann
auch bitte wieder schnell dabei ist weil
das ja das ist einfach nervend
aufreibend und ich habe immer das Gefühl
ich möchte so meinen Zuschauern oder
euch dann meiner Community dann davon
erzählen weil natürlich dann auch meine
Leistung weniger wird wenn sowas in
meinem Leben stattfindet also ich bin
dann natürlich weniger kreativ und
motiviert tolle lustige Inhalte zu
machen wenn ich im Hintergrund sowas
laufen habe was mich dann emotional
vielleicht auch so mitnimmt aber
gleichzeitig kann ich euch irgendwie
nicht davon erzählen und kann euch sagen
hey das und das und das ist los und
deswegen ist gerade bei mir also ich
habe immer das Gefühl ich wirke eher
dann faul und als ob ich keine Ideen
mehr habe und unmotiviert wäre als das
ich euch sagen kann was wirklich los ist
gibt es 2023 endlich ein Adventskalender
von dir ein eigener Adventskalender ist
ein riesen Traum von mir aber ich muss
ehrlich sagen als ich letztes Jahr den
Sally Adventskalender ausgepackt hat der
wirklich ein toller Adventskalender war
Sally Produkten und man hat ihn bei
Sally auf dem Shop bestellt und dann gab
es noch Sally Gutscheine wirklich
physische Gutscheine und dann gab sogar
noch eine gratis Schneidematte oben
drauf und es gab noch ein 25 und 26
Türchen dieser Kalender hatte alles und
dass der Grund warum ich noch gestresst
dann so ein Kalender denke denn diese
Kalender wo man 70 € zahlt und 300 €
Inhalt bekommt das ist ja mega cool aber
das sind ja auch meistens andere Arten
von Deals die dahinter stecken und
andere Möglichkeiten die diese Kalender
haben und ich habe das Gefühl ich habe
dazu beigetragen und die Leute haben
sich einfach daran gewöhnt dass es
solche Angebote geben muss
leckere Kaffee Alternativen und wie
läuft es ohne Koffein ohne Koffein läuft
es noch sehr gut ich vermisse Koffein zu
keinem Zeitpunkt was ich schade finde
dass ich sehr selten koffeinfreie Cola
findest es gibt nur ganz wenige
Supermärkte die das wirklich anbieten
tolle Alternativen sind Minztee so ein
schöner Minztee auch vielleicht mit
Eiswürfeln super lecker Roibuschtee mit
ein bisschen Milch ist auch toll und
koffeinfreier Kaffee für immer Berlin
oder irgendwann zurück in die Heimat ich
habe keine Ahnung ich meine wir haben
uns jetzt eine Wohnung in Berlin gekauft
mit Kredit nicht vergessen ich wir haben
sie nicht auf einen Schlag gekauft und
ich bin mega dankbar ich hatte halt
einen Startkapital mit dem ich diesen
Kredit dann überhaupt erst kriegen
konnte und darüber bin ich so dankbar
also ich bin ein relativ sparsamer
Mensch ist mir aufgefallen ich gebe echt
nicht viel Geld aus für Luxusartikel
mein größtes Geld die pleasur sind so
Lebensmittel halt einfach essen gehen
sich schöne Lebensmittel Supermarkt
kaufen ich glaube das noch so ein Ding
aus der Kindheit und Jugend weil wir
hatten Geld aber wir hatten
Liste da gab es halt keine Extras und
jetzt gönne ich mir halt sehr sehr gerne
extra trotzdem würde ich gerne wieder
auf dem Land leben irgendwann ich glaube
nur dass sie Umgewöhnungszeit ganz schön
heftig sein wird denn in Berlin hat man
einfach alles immer zu jeder Zeit und
ich bin daran so gewöhnt dass es glaube
ich schwierig ist wenn man dann auf dem
Land lebt und plötzlich kein Flieger
deine Lebensmittel innerhalb von 5
Minuten liefert was auch irgendwie total
perverses Timo nicht wollen da mal
wieder runterkommen und nicht die ganzen
Angebote annehmen hast du schon
Reisepläne für 2023 ich habe kein
wirkliches Reiseziel aber ich würde
dieses Jahr gerne Deutschland mehr
entdecken wir waren im Dezember nämlich
in Konstanz ich weiß nicht ob es
wirklich Konstanz heißt aber das ist am
Bodensee da unten das war so cool dass
ich mir echt dachte in Deutschland gibt
so viele Orte die man sich anschauen
kann und besonders Brandenburg hat so
viel schöne Natur die ich mir jetzt echt
mal anschauen möchte und z.B noch der
ganze Norden also die Nordsee die ganzen
Inseln ich habe das Gefühl in
Deutschland gibt so viel dass man gar
nicht so weit wegfahren muss und letztes
Jahr war ich ja in Las Vegas und
Südkorea das waren zwei langen
Streckenflüge und zwei wirklich große
Reisen für meinen Geschmack braucht
jetzt nicht gleich die nächste große
Reise sage ich euch ehrlich auch mit dem
Wohnungskauf finanziell brauchst für
mich erstmal sowas gar nicht wenn ich
aber mal eingeladen werden sollte
vielleicht noch mal nach Südkorea zu
fahren fliegen dann könnte ich nicht
nein sagen aber ja unnötiger Gegenstand
den jeder haben sollte den bekommt ihr
jetzt wartet ich meine ich werde dieses
Jahr 30 ich weiß es schockiert die
meisten von euch mich selbst auch und
wenn man fast 30 ist dann darf man sowas
kaufen mein Gott verdammten Fussel
Rasierer dieses Ding ihr könnt euch
denken rasiert Fusseln
ist es nicht das geilste Ding ever das
ist einfach ein Foto Rasierer ich habe
so viele Hosen Mützen Schals Pullis die
ich nicht mehr gerne trage weil sie
irgendwie abgefuselt sind manche haben
ja dann auch noch diese Knötchen das ist
dann so richtig komisch aussieht dieses
Ding ist bei mir dauerhaft in Benutzung
und ich habe immer noch nicht alle meine
Sachen weg rasiert und ja ich verlinke
euch das natürlich mit einem affilia
Link in der Videobeschreibung dann könnt
ihr euch das Nachkaufen von Marvin
approved ich finde es sehr gut ich bin
so kurz davor so ein chinesischer
Livestream Account zu werden der nur
noch so Sachen verkauft
this is Lifestream Shopping one of the
heart is trance and rider und da sehe
ich mich ich sehe mich ich sehe mich
überhaupt
andrehen wie schaffst du es so ein
wunderbarer toller Mensch zu sein der
immer gut aussieht Spaß ist Standlicht
und die allerwichtigste Frage was machst
du mit den ganzen
adventskalenderprodukten du wirst doch
da mit Zeugs eingemüllt diese Frage
beantworte ich jetzt hier eigentlich
eher dem Finanzamt als euch also könnt
ihr schon abschalten die Adventskalender
Produkte die verlose ich immer zum Ende
meiner ganzen Adventskalender Videos
verlose ich alle Produkte in
Adventskalender drin also ich befehle
die wieder und behalte nicht mal die
Kartons von den Adventskalender vielen
Dank fürs zuschauen ich hoffe euch hat
dieses Video gefallen vielen Dank an
anniffen für die Unterstützung und ich
freue mich auf einen fantastisches 2023
mit euch ne wirklich ich bin gespannt
ähm habe ich über oder habe ich mich
aber verloren ich habe Lust auf neue
Formate stimmt da habe ich über neue
Formate geredet ich habe Lust auf neue
Formate und ich bin sogar am Sprechen
und so mit neuen Formaten also ich
glaube dieser Kanal ist noch lange nicht
tot spätestens zum September wird er mit
den Adventskalender Videos wiederbelebt
richtig schön animiert ansonsten
das nächste Mal wieder und es geht jetzt
wahrscheinlich hier wöchentlich weiter
ich versuche ein bisschen mehr Shorts
und sowas zu machen weil auch ich muss
irgendwann mal mit der Zeit gehen auch
wenn ich es nicht möchte aber hochkant
hochkant Kurzvideos das ist die Zukunft
toll bis zum nächsten Mal tschüssi